good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast and ha
peace
Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday everybody is
looking forward to the weekend weekend
Friday Friday get it down Friday
looking forward to the weekend that girl
knew what she was [__] talking about
okay fun fun fun
period looking forward to the weekend
your words have never been spoken they
have not I'm looking forward to the
weekend are you I am looking forward to
the weekend any big plans uh not big
plans like some little things tomorrow
but really just relax in playing
dying really just like playing in the
playpen all weekend and finishing my
book for the redheads which is kind of
turning out to be the best redheads book
of all time no and you know I don't say
that lightly whose choice Rebecca's
Choice wow I know she must be feeling
really proud I don't know if she started
it I wonder what snitch things but I
actually was FaceTiming with Dana this
morning and we were talking about the
book and like we're obsessed it's so
easy to get into and then you really
can't put it down like my mind is there
wow I love that I think even maybe you
might like it except I have no idea how
it's gonna end like where are we going
with this we're reading the measure by
Nikki Ehrlich like it's the time you
guys is that a Jewish Queen author
erlich
it might be or any relation to the
Christian Max Ehrlich formerly related
to Demi Lovato formerly engaged to Demi
Lovato literally that what a time that
was do you think Max Ehrlich is writing
under a pseudonym
because he's so ashamed of his behavior
when he was engaged to Demi I think he
should
damn throwback I didn't expect to be
thrown back today well I actually have a
lot of time to read this weekend because
I have two really long flights I'm and I
know like nobody cares but I'm just
updating everyone on my Vegas flight
journey I found a better flight JetBlue
thank God so I won't be able to watch my
special which I actually like it almost
didn't stop me from booking the flight
but not enough for a better seat you
know I understand turkey's got to look
out for turd turd's looking out for
number one and that's turd and I got my
Adele tickets and they're good like I'm
excited what are you gonna wear you
better look nice you always look nice
though or you've been loving a miniskirt
lately I have oh my God and I did uh I
bought a mini skirt and like I wasn't
sure if it was gonna work so I wasn't
gonna get anything so crazy I got it
from Zara I think it was like 30 and lo
and behold what do I say
um Ariel charnis wore the same skirt and
you know she doesn't wear Zara lightly
no and I was feeling I was feeling quite
elevated Rich classy so are you gonna
wear that skirt to the concert tonight
no so I actually have a bunch of clothes
arriving today from stout
sickening look at the obsession girly I
thought maybe it was time to like really
you know show up in Vegas like sparkles
also I think it's like cold so I gotta
figure that out
um
but there is like historic weather
happening this always [__] happens no
I know there actually is weather in
Vegas right now but like you really
never leave the hotel and then the
hotels are so close and the cabs come
like right under the it's true the hotel
the hotel where there's still AC or heat
and then you go to another hotel with
the same situation like you're literally
never in the weather so true Vegas is
kind of like a well-oiled machine like
they get you in and out they are a
well-oiled machine which is maybe why I
like it so much because it's efficient
they organize doing they know what they
stand for it's also glamorous you know
people in Vegas like they dress up I
feel like every time you're out in New
York it's like who's wearing dirty or
sweatpants and in Vegas it's glamor it's
Blazers on the men it sparkles on the
women people from all different walks of
life showing up and showing out yeah but
you could also find those who are
dressed down right which you know those
are my people too let me look at me
today yeah yeah but you're just
preparing because you have like a black
tie weekend coming up yeah I'm really
excited like I have heard that the Adele
show is like a it's a moving experience
yeah no um I've heard that too I would
have loved to go by the way if it's
sickening we will plan I know you need
like more than you know 48 hours notice
like you have a child I never said that
like I literally even said yesterday
like I want to come and still the
conversation was switched to how about
how I'm a victim or something by the way
you are
um and literally like I can't deal with
people who need to be handled you want
to come book a flight I'll find you a
ticket like you know what I mean she's
gonna like okay I'm not just gonna book
like invite myself and book why I
already have a hotel room that just come
oh my God like that's crazy
like I can't deal if you like we're
family I'm going with Brian and John
they're family too like you want to come
come
now you're yelling at me no cause like
Brian and John were already going and I
was like oh I'm coming and I just did it
you know what I mean like just insert
yourself sis like have some balls no but
like
don't be shy why don't you so shy I'm
not shy when she McGee you're being shy
why not I'm just like I would have liked
to plan to like be a part of the process
that's not just like a hanger on that's
what I'm saying so if it's amazing we
will plan the process we will like you
know make spa appointments like we will
do a whole weekend not 24 hours in and
out I literally land I have a hair
appointment and then I'm going to like
it's in and out yeah you're not like
that no in and out it kind of works for
me okay okay
so whatever you'll Scout it out let us
know if it's worth our time money energy
Etc I feel I mean it's turning out to be
like a [__] expensive weekend but you
know what I said I was saying yes to
life this year
and I said this to Brian yesterday when
I was like contemplating you know like
the price I was like you know what money
comes and goes Adele is forever
some things are Priceless though you
won't know till it's over so they're
making an investment what's worse than
like spending a lot of money on
something you think is going to be
Priceless and like it's not that happens
to me a lot no I never spend money on
something like thinking it's going to be
Priceless but I I'll spend the money and
I'll be like I think it'll be worth this
and then unexpectedly it was priceless
oh no I like I live in rose-colored
glasses so I'm like everything is going
to be Priceless I'm going to be
remembering this when I'm 80 and then
like I can't even remember it the next
day
well that's just 30. but that's just my
saying yes to life mentality yeah maybe
that's what you need to tell yourself in
order to say yes to life because if it's
not going to be Priceless why would you
put a price on it maybe I should give
like a q1 update to everyone on how it's
going saying yes to life like I have
been saying yes like I've been going out
on weeknights like that's so not me
um Let me give everyone an update
it's going really well I will say like
I'm happy I'm saying yes to life I'd be
lying if I said I wasn't so tired like
people who are always doing stuff and I
was saying this last night to Taylor
strucker
um my God my social battery I also
saying it to Ben last night like my
social battery and my willingness to be
out of my house is getting so like with
every day that passes is decreasing and
I don't know what to do about it
Maybe
you're having a reaction to saying yes
to life even though I love this era for
you but maybe like you need to conserve
your battery and charge up more and
you're not getting a full charge in
between battery sessions but like I'm
having a lot of fun at the things I'm
saying yes too you know what I mean and
I don't think you're saying yes to
nonsense me neither I think it's just
like a busy time of year
bless you she sneezed on it it's true
it's a busy time of year yeah why don't
you book like a massage
Sunday morning in Vegas I tried they
were like so packed I was like lucky to
get my hair appointment at the spot you
know oh that's so annoying I remember
when we went to Vegas for your birthday
snitch and I booked massages like for
after checkout so we like brought our
luggages to the spa and then we had the
spa day pass or no we didn't even get
massages we got a spa day pass and we
got we hung out there till the flight we
were Jello by the time the flight came
around we were so relaxed you should do
that I should do that even though my
flight's in the morning like I don't
that's so pretty
that's so turdy it's the future she
can't see
um you just reminded me of something
luggage
plural
is luggage or luggage is is it like
Goose geese what is it fish the luggage
no luggage could be one or many
right
interesting yeah
learn something new here every day
because it's it's like an umbrella term
whereas the suitcase says but luggage is
kind of an idea all of our luggage is
over there yeah because it's the idea
of what's inside you know what I mean no
because I think like a singular luggage
is like one suitcase but multiple
suitcases is luggage
no but we tied our little away suitcase
we took our luggage
right
that's what I just said no no you said
you think of luggage as one suitcase I
don't know it could be both yes no oh
I'm saying the same thing oh I love
agreeing with you it's so harmonious
which it's not acrimonious no oh my God
ever since you introduced acrimony into
my life I've been saying it all the time
like I was saying something to Zach
about like Harmony and he was like well
what do you mean no like about whatever
I was saying and I was like well it was
an acrimony
I'm telling you and he's like a helpful
word it just kind of like I know he
still didn't know what I was saying he's
just gonna shut him up yeah no it's like
I got a big word shut up I know I have
two but now it's over yeah acrimony is a
good word I'm so glad we're like using
it in everyday life remember when we
used to do word of the day here at the
toast but I feel like we kind of do
inadvertently like word of the week we
always are hung up on a word oh if that
ate our brand to a t what word are we
hung up on this week turd turd no
acrimony I would say like would be like
our SAT Word of the week you know for a
couple months it was nefarious for a
couple years it was the battery there's
one word that I feel like I'm always
saying right now oh lay person lay
person of the lay variety I'm always
saying um
no I don't know I didn't even know what
I was gonna say and of course there's
wench which is something that we've
reintroduced into the vocabulary it's
got that it's kind of like a Word of
Life not a word of the week you know no
I know I think it's here to stay but it
is new to our vernacular oh speaking of
nothing you just said but I just
remembered I wanted to talk about it
um last night we hosted like an
influencer event for spritz because
for those who don't know there's like a
chain of restaurants in New York called
rubies and it's like everyone's obsessed
with it and now Spritz is being sold in
all the rubies locations so we had like
an influencer dinner to celebrate and I
got home and I just had this thought
that I wanted to share
because I feel like and it's especially
pertinent because we recorded a patreon
episode like a week ago about influencer
influencer culture and how like people
are always ragging on influencers and I
feel like people are always really
especially ragging on New York City
influencers like there's all these tick
tocks being made about it people are
always like saying really kind of like
mean things about the New York City
influencers and when I got home last
night I was just like thinking about how
how wrong everyone is about influencers
and about the New York City influencers
because so many of them showed up last
night for the brand and you know these
are girls who get paid to do this and
you know we're a very small company and
they all just showed up tagging having
so much fun they were like chugging
Spritz like they were being so cute they
all went out afterwards like with girls
that they knew girls that they didn't
know and it was like almost like a
sorority Vibe and I was like thinking
I'm like oh my God how wrong people are
I'm sure you know like every job on the
planet there's like mean influencers
just like there's mean teachers or Moon
firefighters like but I feel like the
that's always the narrative and what I
saw last night I was just like looking
around I'm like these girls are so nice
and like they showed up some of us some
of them I don't know some of them I know
some of them I know through snitch but
they just like showed up and we're so
happy to support the brand we're being
so cute and like taking a million
pictures and they're just like such nice
girls and I was like oh my God everyone
is so wrong about like the stigma
especially about New York City
influencers like they're clicky like
really because I was doing the seating
and Margaret was telling me like who
knows who and who doesn't know who and I
was worried I was like I wanted everyone
to sit next to someone they know they
all were just like having a ball and I
just wanted to shout out to all of them
you know they were so nice that is so
nice I definitely feel like there's you
know some misconception maybe a couple
bad experiences but also a lot of
jealousy yeah oh my god of course you
know like I'm jealous of them like
they're just young and like perfect and
like nice like I would be jealous too
yeah so
you've got to understand that I just
think it's important like okay whenever
anyone has a bad experience with an
influencer like they take to tick tock
well I had a fabulous experience and I'm
taking to my podcast you should make a
tick tock you should say this on Tick
Tock because of course like our podcast
listeners love to hear everything you
have to say but I feel like this like
could go viral on Tick Tock in the same
way those negative ones do like they
were all leaving putting their quotes on
I'm like thank you guys so much like I
hope it sounds so late like you guys can
get like good sleep because it's still a
week night I was like oh we're going to
Spring Lounge like we're going to get
dragons I'm like yes like they were all
just like being cute so cute with their
salads and I was just I got home and I
was like you know what people need to
hear this I think you should say it on
Tick Tock like I think that would be
good content for you and you could start
like a new trend where it's like we
don't just need to talk about like the
negative experiences that we have with
people especially when there's a lot of
context that is missing from those
videos and you should just say like
these girls were great girls here's what
they did they supported the brand I feel
like another brand or like if they had
wanted to you know put together a Media
Kit for what they did for us I was
saying some of those girls would have
charged like thousands of dollars for
stories and photos and like taking
pictures with the cans and just like
being supportive and they just showed up
because they either like love the toast
or they know Margo or they just were you
know happy to be invited and it was so
nice supporting their fellow influencers
yeah it was just really it was lovely
and I wanted to say that because
I feel like nobody talks about the
positive you know what you could do
since I know you're like not loving my
idea of making a tick tock about this no
I am I could just see people stitching
it and being like this girl you know
what I mean oh no but you should just
like do a reel from what you just said
right now that way yeah that way it's in
line with your other content native to
your platform yeah I love that but still
you're saying something that the talkers
want to hear because even if they don't
agree with you and they're about to you
know rip you to shreds they love hearing
about influencers they do they do
um not in a positive way but yeah I
agree
yeah
yeah but just sprinkle it in you know it
won't be until the video is over that
they realized that they just had to
consume some positive content yeah
um so that was fabulous if you're in New
York or you find yourself in New York go
to Ruby's the food was so [__] good
people were like the menu looked
sickening oh man and everyone's always
talking about rubies like it's so good
and I had never been and you know me
like if everybody likes something I have
to hate it so I'm like oh it's probably
not that good when I tell you I was not
okay the food was so [__] good like I
don't know I don't think people really
usually like eat heavily at those
dinners but the menu was so good yeah
it's uh we were talking last night and I
I know what rubies is and for some
reason like I thought they're like an
Australian restaurant right
um but the menu it was an Australian
restaurant it is but the menu was in
Australia and I think it's like just
owned by an Australian but they just
have this like reputation as being like
the Australian restaurant they are
Australian like that's what they say
that yeah but like
the menu was like there was panel vodka
no I know I know oh yeah
what is an Australian restaurant make
you think of
Jimmy no good guess what does an
Australian Outback Steakhouse no good
guess
okay wait what does an Australian
restaurant make me think of
oh that Mary Kate and Ashley moving no
another amazing guess I have literally
no idea what the [__] you're about to
say Ashley Darby and Michael's
restaurant oh yeah and also a very good
pop culture reference yeah and that was
an Australian restaurant right and
that's why it wasn't successful no it
was a little too Australian for the
Americans it was a little too authentic
which is why I think Ruby is such a
success because you clearly have a blend
yeah the food was so good oh my God so
um it was a fabulous night I'm just
saying yes to life you know tonight I am
taking off I'm gonna like
charge up before Vegas even though it's
so funny how like social battery works
because I was actually having this
conversation with Ben last night like
there are certain people like you could
be around socially but you don't feel
like you need battery do you know what I
mean yeah and that's like Brian and John
like I feel like if I'm tired like I
could just sit there in silence no but
you just need like actual battery to
like Walk The Halls of Vegas to stand at
the concert I know get on a flight
that's a different sort of battery a
hundred percent that's physical battery
which I'm always depleted of no matter I
could sleep a month and I would wake up
with five percent battery so physically
yeah
I don't know what that is I think it's
like a genetic predisposition like you
know my ancestors things like that
I don't think I've ever met a Jewish
person who has like tons of energy
no I I know some you do yeah
I feel like my friends have tons of
energy okay let me rephrase I don't feel
like I've ever met a Jewish person who
wasn't down just to chill
oh they're always down but they're
always also down like even when we were
chilling like they were playing
pickleball when we were all here so true
oh my God your friends are kind of toxic
[Laughter]
um so that's my week that's my q1
saying yes to Life Update I'll be sure
to check in in Q2 great
yeah
what was your resolution
I just gotten my license so I wasn't
putting that sort of pressure on myself
and how many times since the new year do
you think you've driven
um
Maybe 10.
okay that's more than I thought it would
be I drove on Monday and I'm driving
again today yes because now I've
realized I was starting when I got my
once I got my license I was just like
well now I'm hitting the road but then I
really realized that I'm really
uncomfortable driving by myself still
and I feel like you know a teenager like
there's a reason why you have to drive
with a companion for six months like it
really is so helpful so now I will drive
with someone else and that makes me feel
better like I'm going somewhere today
Zach has to accompany me as my companion
but I will be driving okay
but I'm I don't want to drive by myself
it would be the furthest I've ever
driven by myself you should do little
drives by yourself like to Olivia's
house yes that's what I've been meaning
to do but then you know turdy life gets
in the way like uh and that's I think my
goal is to like just do like a little
Drive every day and like practice
parking and this and that but like
your girl is busy
listen we run a successful business
you're a mother you're a wife you're a
sister you're a disorder you're a Teresa
Giudice daughter and you know what
man plans yeah and then who Jackie man
plans and then who am I
[Laughter]
God
yes
so I'm excited for my drive today see
where my skills are at my skills are
pretty good I just need to get more
comfortable that's what everyone says of
course you know and it's so true I like
having someone in the in the passenger
seat to be like is it safe to switch
lanes as opposed to me like you know
white knuckling and like turning turning
over yeah yeah but then turning in and
then coming back because Yeah a hundred
percent no
changing lanes is like I feel like the
last thing you get comfortable doing
like I'm still always a little
I feel like the last thing I'll be
comfortable with is parking oh for sure
that's why you just have to go to the
mall because the mall has valet I know
can I get my groceries at the mall
work on it why don't you petition the
local Town Council literally mothers who
can't drive
mothers who don't really want to drive
you can start one of those non-profits
you know like Mothers Against Drunk
Driving you should do mothers who can't
park yeah or I get I try and get as many
of my groceries online as possible like
I do Thrive Market but that's a crutch
that's a crutch it is no but like in New
York I got my groceries online and also
like
like I used to when I moved down here
it's like I'm gonna go to the grocery
store yeah
um but like it's a lot to like go every
week and get like a heaping cart full of
stuff and like get it out and I think
I'm just gonna I want to go back to
ordering groceries online like I'll go
to the grocery store you know when I
want a soda and like a little snack and
make it a fun a little bit like a sweet
little treat but I need to go back to
getting my groceries delivered
because I don't like I I it's just not
for me
wow maybe you should come back to New
York then sounds like you'd fit in
no I feel like everybody's doing it
oh oh my God you know what Ben was in
the studio yesterday because Good Guys
recorded an episode probably with the
most famous person who's ever been on
any of our TNN shows and those freaks
have been podcasting for six months and
they get like the guest of all guests
um and when I got here this morning like
everything was different you know like
the camera was like a little move the
computer was a little move my table with
all of my supplies you know my hair my
lip my fan my scrunchie my water my
tissues was cleared it's just like
everything is off now so I just dropped
my phone because like the exact
place it was yesterday is not where it
is yes also when you just said good guys
I thought you said food guys which makes
me realize like that it's just their the
name Electro that should be the name of
their show it's one letter off literally
and it's all they talk about and it's
all they talk about yeah so stay tuned
for that episode coming out I think you
guys are gonna quake and there's also
you know I'm not gonna spoil it okay
without further Ado yeah here are the
past five stories that you need to know
before you embark on your weekend
today's episode is sponsored by State
Farm the State Farm personal price plan
helps you create a plan that gives you
options so you get an affordable price
and it comes with a lot of benefits like
the coverage you want a policy that
helps cover what's important to you and
an affordable price that's made just for
who you because after all life is just
better when you can personalize your
experiences I mean Jax are we not always
saying that like how personal is comedy
how personal is food how personal is
poetry how personal is literally like
anything not more personal than
Insurance I'll tell you that right it's
like we all have different needs we all
have different homes we all have
different everything so it's like why
would we not have like a hella
personalized insurance plan just for us
hella because some people say hello and
some people don't that's pretty personal
too yeah I mean I disagree I think
everyone should be saying hello but I
hear your point personalization means
you have the power to choose what you
want to include and what you want to
leave out it just feels better that way
and why shouldn't insurance work like
that too and that's what the State Farm
personal price plan is all about you can
choose to include options like bundling
your home and auto policies which means
you'll get the coverage you want at an
affordable price just for you and in the
end you'll have a policy that gives you
what you want doesn't that feel better
like a good neighbor
State Farm is there call or go to
statefarm.com today to create your State
Farm personal price plan prices vary by
state options selected by customer
availability and eligibility May Barry
thank you State Farm for sponsoring
today's very special Friday edition
episode of the toast today's episode is
also sponsored by Perfect bar if you're
looking for a protein bar that actually
tastes good well look no further than
the perfect bar with their lineup of
fresh from the fridge protein bars
perfect bar is exactly what you've been
looking for no chalky artificial
aftertaste here
they're made with freshly ground nut
butter organic honey and over 20 organic
superfoods perfect bar has a variety of
products like protein bars little snack
size bars that are also good and good
for you you'll be sure to find something
you love they have tons of different
flavors for whatever your palette is I'm
more of a Savory girl but sometimes I
like a little salty so that dark
chocolate chip peanut butter one with
the little sea salt flakes Heavenly and
I love that you keep it in the fridge
because it's got It's got a nice crunch
to it when you take it out throw it in
your purse I got a long day I actually
have a bar in my bag because I got
meetings till five today on a Friday
which should be illegal they have a
cookie dough texture that's creamy and
full of flavor they're unlike any other
bars out there and now the snack size
which is the perfect size they're packed
with up to six grams of protein and 150
calories so a little goes a long way
perfect thing to hold you over between
meals you know give you that energy that
boost in the middle of the day they're
made with whole food ingredients they
contain no artificial preservatives if
you aren't convinced already there are
also non-GMO project verified they're
gluten-free soy free low GI and kosher
which we appreciate an ally perfect bar
knows that it'll be Love At First Bite
so for a limited time they're offering
you a chance to try their refrigerated
protein bars for free here's how it
works sign up for email or text upload a
picture of your receipt from your local
grocery store and they'll reimburse you
for the cost of one bar it'll go
directly into your venmo or your PayPal
account which is pretty cool all you
have to do is go to perfect snacks.com
toast to get that free perfect bar today
that's perfect snacks.com toast to get a
free perfect bar today happy snacking
happy snacking
great let's dive in tell me what's going
on in the world today Jax first story
Little legal news
Harvey Weinstein has been sentenced to
another 16 years in prison Harvey
Weinstein was sentenced on Thursday to
another 16 years in prison for
sex-related crimes the disgraced
Hollywood producer 70 is already serving
a separate 23-year sentence for raping
and aspiring actress and sexually
abusing a TV and Film Production
assistant of which she was convicted in
March 2020. the latest ruling pertains
to Weinstein's La trial which concluded
in December 2022 with a guilty 2022 not
2020 as well sorry with the guilty
verdict on three counts forcible rape
forcible oral copulation and sexual
penetration by foreign object of Jane
Doe one an Italian model at the Mr C
hotel in the city in February 2013.
he was found uh not guilty of sexual
battery by Restraint of Jane Doe three a
massage therapist at the time so 16 more
years for Harvey already serving a
23-year sentence he's 70 years old this
is jail for life oh wow I didn't even
put that together I didn't realize how
old he was he's been like in the
paparazzi photos he's been looking so
Haggard and disgusting
um because he is but I feel like as
opposed to how he used to look right so
true
um but I felt like it's you know they
always do that it's like look at me I'm
an old man like who could I have hurt
um but I didn't really realize he was
70. wow he's really going to spend the
rest of his life in prison yeah and I
feel like this I don't know when all
this started in terms of uh his
comeuppance at least five years it's
been a while he was in his early 60s now
he's 70. but he's already been serving
time in prison
um
I'm glad justice has been served and
that he will be in prison for his life I
feel like we're always like coming on
here and like talking about how the
justice system has like failed another
time you know something like this is so
gorgeous it's so just and no amount of
time
will be too much ever and I'm so glad
that that this happened I do feel though
in a way you know obviously Harvey
Weinstein was like the biggest and the
baddest perpetrator of you know sexual
abuse in Hollywood and the homie too
movement and I feel like a lot of people
feel like because he he's like not that
he's being made an example because
he did that [__] and he deserves it but
I feel like everyone's like oh well we
solve the problem and it's just like
it's there's so many Harvey Weinstein's
and I feel like okay we got one guy in
jail there's like 50 of them yeah and
there's also like
guys exactly like Harvey like big
Harvey's little Harvey's middle Harveys
like they're Harvey's all over it's a
culture of Hollywood
um I feel like this allows people to
think like we've solved sexual
harassment and inappropriate sexual
behavior in Hollywood I don't from what
I understand like that's not the case
but
some justice is better than no justice
yeah I just feel like everyone like it's
like oh me too like we won but like you
really didn't yeah you got the worst of
them for sure like he's Far and Away
like the number one worst but like
I feel like there's so many others who
are like on his level yeah
and then there's kids stuff too of
pedophiles of course we can't even get
into that that's like a whole other
episode
um I don't know it's like it's good but
there's like so much more and I feel
like there's no there no one else is on
trial
no
I'm trying to think who is and there now
there's some people I don't know where
their trials landed but like Kevin uh
yeah his trial landed fine like nothing
happened to him yeah Bill Cosby
that's true that's true
um
the guy from That 70s Show
yes you're right Danny something
Masterson yeah
so
yeah no you're right I also just feel
like you know there's like known people
in Hollywood who have like you know
accusations out there about them and
they're just like slowly creeping their
way back to where they were before you
know like it's they're like unfazed yeah
well I was upsetting I know you would
hope something like this would phase
them it's like right do you want to
spend your whole life in prison right
I don't know
um so some good legal news yes we we
love to see the justice system out there
doing its thing yeah our next story is
an update from yesterday just a weird
Saga of the week Selena Gomez and social
media Selena is taking a social media
break amid the Haley Bieber drama she is
leaving social media for now at least
the star has been getting busy online in
recent days sharing sultry snaps
commenting on a resurface video of Haley
Bieber which we'll talk about and
weighing in on internet drama however
she revealed she's going to be calling
it quits amid the silly drama with Haley
she said she started she said in a tick
tock live quote I'm very happy I'm so
blessed I have the best friends and the
best fans in the whole world and I just
couldn't be happier
I'm good I love the way I am I don't
care and yeah I'm gonna be taking a
second from social media because this is
a little silly and I'm 30. I'm too old
for this I agree I love you guys so much
and I will see you guys sooner than
later I just have to take a break from
everything
so this has been a very strange week for
Selena Gomez because she's been in the
headlines a lot but by her own doing
she's kind of been acting very bizarre
on social media
um and I feel like a lot of people are
like concerned for her because she's
obviously been very open at her struggle
with like lupus but also her mental
health and it just feel like some of
this behavior is like a little erratic
like it's reminding me a little bit of
like on a much smaller scale but like
Britney almost
so different but and I saw those
concerns a little bit and I just
want to be cautious because I don't like
when like someone does something that
you disagree with and then you're like
oh well that's because uh she has
bipolar disorder and it's right she
could also just like feel that way you
know what I mean like no that's true it
could be that her she you know she's
going through something right now but
could also just be like no this is
Selena's personality and she's online
doing her thing I know but it is so
uncharacteristic of her and the live I
watched her Tick Tock live clip where
she was saying she's going off social
media she just did see seem kind of like
all over the place and very unseling
alike
yeah but I feel like we also don't get
that many glimpses into true live Selena
do you know like she's been going live
more recently but I feel like she's been
keeping up this energy of like really
engaging with stuff I mean Haley con 10
is kind of to a different level and so
maybe it's her people being like we need
to let this settle down because like uh
I don't know that this is the right look
for us
um
and and or maybe she is experiencing a
mental health uh Crisis crisis but I
just I always just want to be cautious
of being like oh she did something I
don't agree with mental health no that's
actually a really good point I
appreciate that
um but let's just backtrack so for
anyone who's like not keeping up with
Tick Tock 24 7 like I am What Selena's
basically been doing these last couple
of days is like leaving comments on
other people's videos about different
subjects so the one that's being
referenced here is a clip of Haley
Bieber like she looks so different it
must be five years ago maybe more
um she looks so young on that show I
think it's lip sync battle uh rap drop
the mic rap battle yeah yeah no so um
she co-hosted dropped the mic in Method
Man reference Taylor Swift's 2017 album
reputation and he said celebrities will
perform a one-on-one rap battle full of
the meanest lyrics about a celebrity
since Taylor Swift's last album and then
Haley like puts her finger in her mouth
um obviously I'm a Taylor stand till I
die and this was literally seven years
ago so you're never not once going to
catch me like oh my God like about
something that happened so long ago so
um Julie Young she's also playing a part
she's on TV like the caption on this
video is this is the real Haley Bieber
oh my God
and then Selena commented on it saying
so sorry my best friend is and continues
to be one of the best in the game
yeah so like this person trying to act
like this one out of context clip from
10 years ago is the real Haley Bieber is
really uh moronic and then Selena
commenting on it and validating it is
real it's my in my opinion like it's
irresponsible like that's in so much
hate Haley's way after like what has
already happened between them like that
was really honestly Selena should not
have done that then people started
making these other videos about Selena
and it's so funny because like they saw
Selena was being active and I feel like
the amount of content about Selena like
tripled in the hopes like I saw
influencers I saw regular people making
complimentary videos towards Selena just
in the hopes that like they would get on
yeah yeah yeah so someone else made a
video and was like you know what I was
thinking about today like I feel so bad
for Selena Gomez you know she was you
know with this guy for so many years
that she was in love with and then two
months later he gets married to a girl
he just met and she has to deal with her
lupus flare-ups and anytime anything bad
is going on in my life I just think like
oh my God it's so much worse for Selena
and it's like okay get a [__] grip
like yes like any human being Selena has
been through you know success and she
of life
um but like let's also keep in mind
Selena's like extremely privileged you
know she has a thriving business like
like let's let's get a grip like she you
don't need she's not like a starving
child in Africa okay right right no that
video when she said that at the end like
whenever I'm having a bad day I just
think about how Selena I was like is
this a parody like that's a joke and
then Selena commented I love you so it's
like yeah you should feel bad for me
it's like well you know I sometimes will
think like wow I'm so privileged I'll
compare my life to you know someone who
lives in a different country and doesn't
have you know anything doesn't have
fresh water like I of course that's a
normal thing I don't think that about
Selena Gomez no no that was really
[__] unhinged honestly it was I was
shocked to see that then Selena
commented on it but to me it's like
of like given the other things that
she's been commenting on like that's not
even that crazy here it's just like a
girl supporting her not even actually
trashing anyone else along the way just
like true true being very supportive of
Selena
they've just been like really bizarre
videos that she's commented on really
kind of um Fanning the Flames videos
that she's commented on towards Haley
towards Flames are being fanned she
commented on another video where you
know someone was talking about how Kylie
and Haley are bullying Selena like how
could those nepo babies know anything
and Selena commented on that like
Selena's being a [__] starter she's in
her shit-starting era yeah and we said
yesterday like she should put the phone
down there is a social media break
upcoming I imagine her team is like put
your phone down because even though I
think mostly people are taking Selena's
side you know the narrative is like the
nepo babies are the Mean Girls and
Selena's just like sad Selena
um
I don't see it that way I think that's
just like what people who are speaking
out are saying and everyone else is like
Jackie that's just what the Selena fans
are thinking and once again nobody
anybody making videos in defense of the
nepo babies
yeah like it's not as much but it's
because the only people making videos
are the Die Hard Selena fans no and
because like just Selena like it's just
like this victim mentality where it's
like why would you you don't want to be
seen to like support the bullies
there's not a strong narrative you know
for the other side who's the third
person in this store like it's Kylie
Haley but there was like a third person
in the video Justine Skye oh okay
there was no Kendall mm-hmm okay
maybe Kendall was in one of them with
Haley
I don't know but it's just Kylie and
Haley that's being you know the bullies
quote unquote right now who are the face
of this yeah it's so dumb and I feel
like nobody would have really thought
much of it if Selena hadn't just gotten
so active and been like yeah they're
targeting me
yeah
so then it's like she commented on the
Kylie one and was like no I don't think
this is about like I love Kylie I'm a
fan blah blah blah
but then she goes and comments on other
videos supporting that Haley and Kylie
are bullies Theory you know
it's like she's just really kind of
encouraging her fans and her fans are
extremely toxic
um I feel like this is a great example
of that and Selena encouraging them is
making it worse and then it's just
encouraging other people who aren't even
invested in this Saga to like make
content because they just want Selena to
comment on it yeah and also like Selena
positioning herself like she's really
the victim like it really makes her fans
feel so um much worse for her yeah no
but so
it like so righteous that they're
standing up for Selena so they don't see
the toxic Behavior it's like Selena
needs us look what's happening we're
Justified yeah yeah no it's it's a bad
look for everyone yeah and I love my
girl Selena like love Yeah but a break
is always good a break you're never
gonna regret taking a break you will
regret not taking a break and that's
from anything not just social media life
in general you know yes you'll never
look back and be like I wish I took less
breaks you know well I mean unless
you're saying it's to life then you're
kind of in a pickle that's true actually
are you ready for our next story yeah I
think I am I really I really do Lucy
Hale
um went on a podcast and it was crying
detailing her incredibly
self-destructive journey to sobriety I
saw a lot of Clips on this and I first
of all loved that she went on a podcast
love Diary of a CEO was the podcast and
I really feel like more and more anytime
a celebrity has something really
profound or like personal to share like
they're always going I mean Kelsea
ballerini like they're always going on
podcasts podcasts really are the new
frontier yeah no it's a perfect medium
to share your story because you can
share until the cows come home until you
feel adequately shared there's no time
constraints or also most people like
have studios in their houses or like big
fluffy chairs they're really kind of
casual and comforting intimate yeah it's
not like this stiff Good Morning America
set with a thousand lights and fans
outside like it's really intimate
exactly that's a perfect word and
nobody's gonna take your words out of
context because like it's you're putting
out your
so true there's no editing no at least
there shouldn't be yeah Lucy hell broke
down in tears reflecting on her
incredibly self-destructive journey to
sobriety when the PLL Alum immediately
teared up during Thursday's Diary of a
CEO podcast episode she warned host
Stephen Bartlett that she cries all the
time speaking about her path she said
quote I just love where I landed in my
life and it's been a really powerful and
painful insightful joyous horrible
Journey she told listeners that she has
been working on getting sober since she
was 20 clarifying that she has had a
problem since she first tried alcohol at
age 14. oh wow she said not only did
drinking quiet her mind which was
exhausting but Hale felt like her real
self under the influence a feeling she
now understands to be [__] she said
I was a textbook binge Drinker blackout
I wouldn't remember what I did or said
although she tried to change for her
boyfriends her mom her career and for
vain reasons she said she had to
personally want to get sober for the
choice to stick on January 2nd 2022. she
said I deserve more out of this life I
have to try it a different way
explaining her lowest moment came after
dozens of emotional Rock bottoms at the
depths of hell she credited her
resilience with always pulling herself
out of hard times and slingshotting
herself the other way
those are the quotes
um I love I love Lucy Hale it's so
interesting how like when I look back in
the last few years and just like my
perception of her like I never would
have guessed that she seemed so you know
put together and so perfect yeah and of
course you did true you really you
really never know like what someone's
going through especially somebody in the
public eye and that's why it's so
important to just like chill and like be
nice to everyone because public private
celebrity non-celebrity like people have
demons and we've known her for so long
she's been famous she I think she got on
PLL when she was like 16 and she had
like a few roles before that yeah so
like we've known her for so long and
she's always been just us like kind of
like America's sweetheart Vibe yeah
she's always been working it seems like
she works hard he would have never
guessed this I feel like so often when
celebrities get sober it's like well we
saw them kind of self-destruct and now
unravel and you know we're on the whole
journey so to know this now I feel like
really her telling her story we've not
heard a celebrity it reminds me of one
other story but we've not really heard a
celebrity story like this like she's
been struggling for 15 years with
sobriety hiding it from yeah the world
really well I feel like this is a sort
of story that really helps people you
know and to like look at themselves and
be like well maybe I don't see myself as
you know uh what I think of as an
alcoholic or someone with a drinking
problem but I'm
you know I'm harming myself and I'm kind
of self-destructing my own life you know
what you just reminded me of this
morning
um Luke Combs yeah really released a new
song called Joe and he put out a
statement just to give some context as
to what the song was about and it was so
moved by his statement and it was so it
was so honest and self-aware and
thoughtful I'm gonna read it
he wrote there have been some folks in
my family that have struggled with
alcoholism and addiction through the
years I've got buddies who live a sober
lifestyle and I'm sure you all know
someone who has struggled with these
types of things or maybe you yourself do
this song Joe is really important to me
for that reason our genre meaning
country music has so many songs about
drinking and partying hell I'm probably
one of the worst culprits of it there's
nothing wrong with that I don't think
but sometimes I wonder what someone in
the crowd who doesn't drink or struggles
with addiction is thinking or feeling
when there's thousands of people around
them screaming beer never broke my heart
or one too many I've always wanted a
song for those people to have for
themselves to have a song they can sing
at the top of their lungs and feel like
they're not forgotten so when Eric
Dillon sent me the work tape of this
song A few years back I knew I wanted to
be a part of it so if you're reading
this and this song speaks to you I hope
you love it this one's for you
I like almost got like emotional reading
and it was so thoughtful and you really
do never think about how everyone has
their own demons and so these things
that are accepted in popular culture
like drinking and just like getting
wasted
um that so many people can deal with in
a healthy way but there are also people
who can't I just thought it was so
I was so moved by it it was so
thoughtful honestly yeah and very
considerate
to everyone I feel like
you know there are more and more people
who are becoming sober either because
they struggle for addiction or they're
just like something about drinking
culture drugs like just doesn't agree
with like their
personal chemical makeup yeah no but
like also just you know it doesn't it
could hinder their like life or their
motivation or their progress their work
you know whatever it is like I rarely
rarely drink
um yeah I was gonna say do you consider
yourself like a sober person I just feel
like sober implies that you had like an
addiction yeah no I mean
uh I don't know what the word for it
would be like the fact that like I I do
not drink except like I would have a
spritz you know when the when the Vibes
are right right I wouldn't have more
than one or two because I don't like the
way that it makes me feel so I don't
consider myself a sober person but I I
identify with sober people yeah yeah
especially because like I used to drink
so much and I it's not like something
that I woke up one day I was like I need
to change my ways and I feel fortunate
that it was just a gradual like natural
thing that I kind of shed but
when people talk about getting sober and
like describing in this way and also
because like I never did anything like
so crazy but like I really relate to it
because it's it it's really harmful like
especially I think when it really
stopped drinking so much when we started
running our own business and it's like
yeah I don't want to be hungover I want
every day to like when I'm working to be
as productive as possible I don't want
to feel like [__] like
I get that yeah of course
so I think it's awesome that you sharing
it reminded me I wanted to say of
Chrissy Teigen I don't know where she
wound up because she was sober for a
while and she would share like why she
got sober house she was always like the
drunk one at the industry events and we
would see her and we thought it was so
awesome and she was so funny but like
the way she would feel the next morning
I think the things that she said she
embarrassed her husband like that's how
she would feel I feel like that was
really relatable yeah because it wasn't
I think that's how a lot of people's
relationship with alcohol is like you'll
do crazy things and you don't feel like
you're an addict and you're not but
you'll do crazy things you just don't
like the way you feel the next day I
think John Mayer talks about it really
well too
um I don't think he really drinks I
think he smokes pot
um just because it wasn't so destructive
but it was just you got tired of feeling
like anxious and embarrassed the next
day yeah
yeah so I think that's awesome that
she's sharing and that she did this and
that she me too it's been a year and I
think it's uh probably was a really good
move that she didn't share until she was
a year sober because it's a lot of
pressure to put on yourself to have it
out there it is but it's also nice to
now to like have that level of
accountability knowing that everyone
knows yeah but it like I they say it's
always really hard when you're like
um a recovering alcoholic but I feel
like quitting those days are harder than
one year in but that's just my
perception of it say it again I feel
like the early days of quitting are
harder
than being one year sober no I think
it's really a struggle every day like
that's what they always say I think
that's what they said right I'm saying
that's what they say
it's like you literally you have to take
every day one day at a time that's
always what they say it's like don't
think about how many days you're behind
you and don't think about how many days
you're ahead of you like just think
about today yeah I think also think
that's a really good um way of thinking
just for anything you know life in
general life can be hard life can be
long like as long as you take it one day
at a time like you're gonna be okay yeah
agreed
I think that's a good mentality are you
ready for our next story only if it's
the next story that's brought to you bye
[Music]
this episode is brought to you by the
bed by thuma now get a 25 credit towards
your purchase of the bed plus free
shipping in the Continental us when you
go to thuma.co toast so Jackie I know
you've had a fabulous experience with
the thuma bed in your house it's in
snitches quarters which is a premium
placement concentra's tough critic so I
couldn't just give her any bed I had to
give her the Sumo bed but I also like
couldn't be spending years you know
taking years off my marriage building a
bed with Zach right we needed something
simple
that was delivered in three easy to
maneuver boxes
thuma that's the beauty of thuma it
arrives in three easy maneuver boxes the
setup time no joke they use Japanese
joinery there's no tools required
I'll say seven minutes they say five
seven five to seven minutes okay it is
so unbelievably different than any
experience you've had setting up a bed
and then the bed itself is really
beautiful it's Timeless it's classic
they have a bunch of different options
they have pieces that are handcrafted
from eco-friendly high quality upcycled
wood it's minimalist it's modern and it
helps Elevate any space they also have
uh so the that's what you have the
platform bed and it just got better
because you can now customize the bed by
choosing the original pillow board or a
new solid wood headboard so they have
fabric options they have wood headboards
that's more solid and Sleek create that
feeling of checking into your favorite
boutique hotel but at home with the bed
by thuma and now go to thuma.co toast to
receive a 25 credit towards your
purchase of the bed plus free shipping
in the continental US that's thuma
t-h-u-m-a dot c o slash toast for 25
credit
t-h-u-m-a dot Co slash toast for 25
thank you Claudia hello welcome our next
Story another celebrity is opening up
Paris Hilton reveals in her new
interview with glamor magazine that she
was roofied and raped at 15 by an older
man
oh my God I didn't hear this yeah this
was yesterday because she is on the
cover of Glamor she's doing like yeah
she has photos out with the baby but
also her book is coming out in a few
weeks so she's like just has a lot going
on right now a lot of people yes but she
sat down for an interview with glamor
and revealed that her first sexual
encounter was non-consensual and
occurred at the age of 15. she claimed
her abuser was an older man she met at a
local mall in California who allegedly
slipped something into her drink and
took advantage of her at the time she
was living with her maternal grandmother
in Palm Springs she told the outlet that
she'd visit LA to see her friends and
hang out at the Westfield Century Center
shopping center almost every weekend she
noted that older guys would always just
be hanging out around the stores and
that she and her Pals would talk to them
and give them their beeper and pager
numbers one day the group of men invited
Paris and her girls to their house where
the miners were allegedly given berry
wine coolers to drink Hilton Who quote
didn't drink or do anything back then
recalled one of the guys being
particularly forced and making her
consume her beverage when I had maybe
one or two sips I just immediately
started feeling dizzy and woozy I don't
know what he put in there I'm assuming
it was a roofie the new mom said she
passed out and woke up a few hours later
knowing that something had happened
quote I remembered it I have visions of
him on top of me covering my mouth being
like you're dreaming you're dreaming and
Whispering that in my ear
oh my God she said the experience
preceded the two plus years that
seemingly uh troubled teen spent at
various expensive behavioral
modification programs including Provo
Canyon School uh which we know she
shared in her documentary this is Paris
um
but she's opening up even more and this
is just so sad
no it's so sad and I just feel like it's
so
I feel like we've been in this last few
years like slowly uncovering like
peeling back the layers of who Paris
Hilton really is and I feel like this is
just a testament it's like how we really
don't know her you know she's so complex
like everyone thinks she's like this
heiress like perfect life and there's so
much there I feel like her book is going
to be amazing like I really I really
feel like it is yeah because she has so
much more to share I feel like her
documentary uh inadvertently wound up
focusing on her years at Provo and then
like the advocacy that she was doing and
the healing she was doing but I that's
only one part of her story and one part
of like the trauma that she went through
so I think her book will really and if
this is like what she's sharing in an
interview like right the book is really
where you go to you know kind of bury
your soul I think she's really gonna do
just that and just be completely honest
I think it's a terrible story a horrible
story first I mean everything was worse
it kept getting worse that's so terrible
yeah so so [__] disgusting and Evil
like Beyond Beyond
uh well I do think her book will I I
feel like I don't know if we'll really
ever know who like the true underneath
all like the makeup I don't know if
we'll really ever know like a hundred
percent the real Paris but I feel like
our the book will get us like uh uh give
us a huge understanding of like what she
became like and how she became it she
became is like Larger than Life she
created this whole like industry of like
in like original influencer and
Paparazzi like she really was that and
it's kind of because she was like
spinning out from this trauma of like
her childhood but also it was a defense
mechanism to like put out someone to the
whole world and everybody thinks that
this is who you are and only I know the
real me yeah
yeah
we'll see but it seems like those walls
are coming down yeah and like and there
will continue to because she's just
right now she's a mom she's a mom and
she's in a different stage of her life
in her career and it's just reflecting
the photos were beautiful of her and the
baby and Carter just like kind of
stripped down her baby's so beautiful
I'm loving this this era for Paris yeah
loving
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
are you saying it's time for
the final story
It's the final story and I want my
dinner
no and there's a magic number
a beautiful rendition from the Beautiful
song
kind of like an acoustic version you
know you should become a pop star like
Hannah Montana where you're under an
alias because obviously like you want to
maintain your life I want you to be able
to come visit me still of course
one name Wonder Ed
turd no turdy turdy that's like the
feminine
Turtle
let me be your turdy
speaking of pop stars one of our
favorites Addison Ray yes
horror movie called Thanksgiving
opposite Patrick Dempsey
Addison is planning to tackle the horror
movie genre according to new reports The
Tick Tock star who nabbed her first
acting role in Netflix's remake of She's
All That titled he's all that which was
an amazing movie that you should watch
that's on Netflix we'll star in a
slasher movie for her sophomore film
according to the Hollywood Reporter the
movie is an Eli Roth movie called
Thanksgiving it's a horror movie which
is based on a faux trailer he made
for Robert Rodriguez and Quentin
Tarantino's double feature grind house
in 2007. who cares yeah I don't know
people though people definitely care no
I just thought someone else was
announced as being in the movie it was
Patrick Dempsey yeah like this is a
legit movie I love that for Addison is
he gonna play her dad
by the way I cannot like think of
anything other than Eli Roth in this
story do you know why
like in on a personal level yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah when we were in high
school he like was dating like this girl
we know yeah they were cute yeah and
he's an Inglorious Bastards he was
fantastic I I only have oh yeah
um positive associations my only
Association is like I didn't even know
who he was except when I was like
literally 14 like one of Olivia's like
older friends was dating him and I was
like who is this guy yeah cute that's
what I think of ship ship
so I don't watch horror movies so I
don't know if I'll make an exception for
Addison I just need to protect my piece
I'm not interested oh okay but I'm glad
that our girl's back to work it's weird
that this is her choice I'm not gonna
lie like whereas he saw that the sequel
where's her starring in Britney biopic
like where's anything other than this
but whatever it's weird but it seems
like it's a pretty legitimate Affair and
I know it's that large type for sure
they are huge they're the ones that like
make all the money these days right and
so I feel like ever like I feel like in
the last couple of years they're not
like this isn't like Paranormal Activity
it's more like Thriller almost I feel
like it's almost going to be in like the
like Jordan peel category I don't know
why it's like artsy Phil 30 no so it's
based on that Quentin Tarantino nonsense
where those films centered around a
group of survivors fighting zombie-like
creatures I'm an action thriller about a
stuntman getting targeting victims with
his killing machine car
um while details of her character are
still unknown sources chill thr that the
film will be centered around a murderer
who comes to a small town in
Massachusetts with the intent of
carving out residents in the town to
create a Thanksgiving board
got it okay I totally misunderstood so
it's definitely like zombie apocalypse
dumb like well carving out residency I
guess that's not like uh Supernatural or
um what's the word that we use all the
time about books Mr normal
paranormal
no it's like nothing to see here that
was
it required a bit of suspense
to be suspended just just suspending
disbelief got it mystical realism
magical realism yes yes
we got it
um yeah no I definitely feel like the
new trend was like really successful
horror movies is like really influenced
by Jordan Peele it's like it's not as
like gory fake blood it just makes you
think right but that's not what this is
I I figured no this might be that what
this is like the other movies were about
zombies but this one is about like a
serial killer who carves out people
okay it still sounds like a little silly
like
silliness yeah
so check out Thanksgiving in the theater
sometime soon yeah no I love this for
Addison hopefully this is like the you
know jump start to the comeback she's
been very quiet I know I miss her every
day
I know she's still like as active on
social media as like an influencer but
really not giving much not like opening
up or sharing or really anything does
she dance on the talk still
more like lip syncs okay cute yeah she's
definitely pulled back
but I feel like her family stuff has
really quieted down like she hopefully
her [__] parents somebody gave him
like a mean talking to and hopefully
they'll just chill the [__] out and shut
the [__] up
you can help one could only dream and so
that you know kind of Paving the way for
a big Addison comeback
BAC but she's also just like happy in
her relationship
happy period yeah these are all
Addison's choices and I have to respect
those yeah true true
and that's our show that is our show and
that's our week
um I'm headed off to Vegas but we are
back in studio regular girlies Monday
through Friday next week
and we'll leave you with that we will
thank you guys so much we'll miss you
for listening to the toast the
millennial Morning Show where we deliver
the past Tech stories that you need to
know everybody through Friday on YouTube
so you're watching us on YouTube please
don't forget to subscribe to give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as podcast anywhere anywhere podcast can
be found everywhere imagine Stitcher
public radio I have radio plus
leave a five-star review about how
beautiful standing and wickedly talented
we are hope you guys have it in Korea
weekend stay safe out there make good
choices drink lots of water brush your
teeth wash your face and we'll see you
tomorrow no we'll see you on Monday bye
love you bye